Let's go next to our color from the four eight
zero area code.
Who is calling today from four eight zero.
Hello, David.
Yeah.
Hi.
Uh, my question is related to the Thanksgiving.
Don't talk politics.
So I was wondering what you had to say about
that subject.
Oh, we did a whole bunch of segments about
that before Thanksgiving.
Is there I, I, I think it's fine to kind of
call it,
I mean, yeah, no, I mean the, uh, the subject
is don't talk politics to Thanksgiving.
Don't talk politics with relatives.
But what about if you're just in line with
strangers?
Uh, you know, people you're never going to
see again and you're not trying to convince
them.
Don't vote for Trump, but, uh, you're just
trying to have a little fun.
Would you ever do that?
I wouldn't do that, but I'm totally fine if
you do it.
I have no problem with other people doing
that.
If that's what they want.
I tend not to talk about politics out in the
world.
I get enough on my show.
So that wouldn't be my instinct.
The last thing I would ever do in line somewhere
or you know, if I see somebody with a Trump
bumper sticker to go up to them and roll down
my window and yell something that I, I don't
do stuff like that.
But if you, if you like that stuff by, you
know, all power to you.
Okay.
I don't know if you want to hear about a short
story just happened to me today.
I'm in line with a bunch of strangers and
a Trump.
This is going on and on about, uh, you know
how Trump's support with blacks is 18 and
it's going to go up to 24%.
You know, the Democrats, why don't they already
decide already?
And Hillary is getting in and I mean, you
just keep going on and on and I'm trying to,
you know, sort of involve myself in the conversation
and you know, but he's just, he says he's
not really a Trump supporter, but you know,
unemployment's the lowest in 50 years and
it's just, it's just,
I mean, I just don't know why, what we can
do because,
so did you get involved or not?
Did you jump in?
No, I tried to.
I tried to and the whole conversation started
with, he was, uh, he was trying to sort of
defend the Catholic church because they just
recently, I think in New Jersey there's a
new law that the statute of limitations, there
is no statute of limitations for, you know,
Catholic abuse.
So he was so the other person in line was
an thing, you know, like that's a big business
for him is his defending people.
And then the, uh, this Trump is trying to
defend the Catholic church saying, Oh, it's
just the internet.
It's just the media.
No, I would not get involved.
It sounds like these, these are conversations
with a lot of people.
I would, I would probably try to avoid talking
to, so that, that would be my advice.
Listen, thank you for the call.
I appreciate it.
Call back in.
If you have any of these other exchanges.
They sound they sound intense.